[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
peloton
I love peloton peloton is a cutting-edge
indoor cycling bike that brings live
studio classes right to your home you
don't have to worry about fitting
classes into your schedule making it to
the studio or dealing with some commute
to the gym I have a peloton bike in my
master bedroom at home and it is one of
the first things that I do in the
morning I wake up meditate for say 20
minutes and then I knock out a short 20
minute ride usually high-intensity
interval training or hit then I take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's beautifully
convenient and has become something that
I actually look forward to and I was
skeptical in the beginning I didn't
think I would dig it and I really do so
you have a lot of options for one if you
like you can ride it live with thousands
of other peloton riders from across the
country on the interactive leaderboard
to keep you motivated I tend to use a
lot of the classes on demand and have
four to six of them that I've bookmarked
and use over and over again there are up
to 14 new classes every day with
thousands of classes on demand and there
are a variety of workouts to choose from
45 minute classes 20 minute burns hip
hop rock and roll low-impact or high
intensity pick the class structure and
style that works for you peloton has an
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in New York City they really do have
great instructors of every possible
personality and style and you can find
one that you love no matter what you're
in the mood for personally I use Matt
Wilbur's a lot but I use a bunch of them
I'm promiscuous and enjoy classes from a
lot of their instructors with real time
metrics you can track your performance
over time and continue to beat your
personal bests
I did not think the gamification would
work for me and they really hit the nail
on the head it does work at least for me
tremendously well to keep me pushing
consistently so discover this
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings us to do experience to your home
peloton is offering listeners of this
pod
a limited time offer go to one pallet
uncom that's spelled o-n-e PE l oto
ENCOM enter the code
Tim podcast all one word at checkout and
get $100 off accessories with your
peloton bike purchase get a great
workout at home any time you want go to
one peloton calm and use the code
Tim podcast to get started this episode
is brought to you by zapier za p IE are
you may in your own mind say zapier but
it's not say p ER its zapier like
happier they are a new sponsor but not
new to me as a service at all i've been
using them for many years now if you run
your own business think about all the
hours and hours maybe
endless hours you spend moving
information from one software program to
another all because they don't easily
work together well now they can
automatically thanks to Sam peer my team
has been using zapier for years as I
mentioned which helps us with a ton of
tasks including let's just take one
example connecting Facebook Ads
campaigns to our email platform you can
also as I do automate the posting of
your Instagram photos to all social
platforms this has saved me and my team
hundreds of hours alone my team has also
raved about zapier support which is very
important if things go sideways you want
to be able to reach someone and in their
words it is in a class of its own a
class of its own that's the exact
verbatim quote from one of my employees
as with all sponsors of this podcast we
try to test everything ourselves and we
have used zapier as full paying retail
customers that is we paid for the
service long before we ever had contact
with the company as a sponsor they
support more than 1,500 business
applications so the possibilities for
automating processes are virtually
endless you may know if you've read the
4-hour workweek that the third step is
automation not adding headcount to a
messy problem to try to fix it but
automating as much as possible you want
to eliminate automate and only then
delegate and zapier is one of the best
pieces of automation software that I've
ever come across
it connects all of your business
software and handles work for you so you
can focus on the things that matter most
the things you're good at for instance
instead of trying to cobble stuff
together or code to learn more try it
out go to zapier dot-com / Tim connect
the apps use most and let zapier take it
from there you can do a million things
as one more example zapier lets you
instantly engage with leads send them to
a CRM or spreadsheet and then notify
your team so they can act fast and like
I mentioned very briefly the beautiful
part is that you can build the solution
you need in minutes without writing code
or asking a developer for help so join
the 4.5 million people or more at this
point who are saving an average of 40
hours per month by using zapier now and
for a limited time tries zap your free
by going to our special link zapier z AP
ier dot-com slash Tim that's
zapier comm slash Tim for your free
14-day trial check it out
zabi ER comm slash tim hello boys and
girls ladies and germs this is tim
ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show my guest today
has a bio that reads almost as
unbelievable Adam grant Adam grant is an
organizational psychologist at Wharton
where he's been the top-rated professor
for seven straight years it didn't
always start out that way and we're
gonna talk about the very beginning he
is an expert in how we can find
motivation and meaning and lead more
generous and creative lives he's the
number one New York Times bestselling
author of four books that have sold more
than 2 million copies and have been
translated into 35 languages give and
take originals option B and power moves
his books have been recognized as among
the year's best by Amazon the Financial
Times Harvard Business Review and The
Wall Street Journal and been praised by
JJ Abrams Richard Branson Bill and
Melinda Gates Malcolm Gladwell and many
many others Adam hosts the TED podcast
work life that's one word work life
capital W capital L and his TED talks
have been viewed more than 20 million
times his speaking and consulting
clients include Google the MBA the Gates
Foundation among others he has been
recognized as one of the world's top 10
most influential management thinkers
fortunes 40 under 40 and a World
Economic Forum young
global leader and has received
distinguished scientific achievement
awards from the American Psychological
Association and the National Science
Foundation
Adam writes for The New York Times on
work in psychology and serves on the
Department of Defense innovation board
he received his BA from Harvard and his
PhD from the University of Michigan and
his former magician and Junior Olympic
springboard diver Adam welcome to the
show
okay it's great to be here and this is
one of those pictures from the bio that
if I were creating a character and a
novel I feel out my editor would
encourage me to clip back on you have a
very impressive
not just bio but time line and the
amount you've done in a very very
compressed period of time so I think
we're going to talk a lot about
productivity habits and things that are
related to that but I want to just bring
up a few other quotes some of the quotes
are from media this one is from the New
York Times quote grant took three years
to get his ph.d and in the seven years
since has published more papers in his
fields top-tier journals and colleagues
who have won Lifetime Achievement Awards
and then there's another note from one
of our mutual friends which says when
another Wharton professor got tenure he
opened his speech by saying quote I'm so
grateful to be in a place where everyone
is focused on the same research question
how does Adam grant do it and that's the
question on my mind and I thought where
we could possibly start is with
rewinding the clock and going back to
your very first experiences teaching and
I have a cheat sheet note here that says
you are so uncomfortable in the
beginning that your first evaluation
forms read at least from one person
quote you're so nervous you're causing
us to physically shake in our seats end
quote so how do you improve at that
point what did you do to improve after
getting those feedback forms oh thanks
for reminding me it was it was painful I
you know I remember going to grad school
and thinking I sort of found my calling
you know I had I had these professors
you changed the way I saw the world and
they were incredibly inspiring and I
wanted to try to pay that forward and
then I go in front of my first audience
and I get comments like that and it
wasn't just one student right it was
over and over and over again
instructor seems very nervous instructor
seems like the most nervous professor
I've ever heard in my life
the director is sweating so much that
I've completely stopped paying attention
to the lecture and it's just it just
went on and on and I I think I did what
anyone would do in that situation since
I started to wonder whether I should
quit and then I started to realize that
the reason I got into this in the first
place was not about me it wasn't it
wasn't about my emotions or my anxiety
or the fact that I was described as
looking like a muppet yeah awkwardly
moved around the stage it was it was
because I loved ideas and I wanted to
share them and I wanted to be helpful to
the students that I would one day teach
and so I guess I took I took a little
cue out of out of my diving days and I
said okay when I started diving I was
really awful what did I do
I did it as many reps as possible every
day it you know it sounds really boring
but last time I checked you kind of
plant the seeds of greatness in the
daily grind and I know you've lived your
whole life that way Tim but for me that
meant I'm I'm gonna go and get in front
of his many audiences as I can and so I
actually started volunteering to give
guest lectures for other people's
classes and force myself into a
situation where I would have to be on a
stage every day I would have to give
multiple talks on the same topic I would
then have to write new talks and you
know I think physiologically you can
only sustain anxiety for so many hours
at a time right and eventually it
started to fade a little bit I started
to get a little more comfortable and
then a couple of a couple good things
happen remember I I cracked a joke off
and after I'd you know done a lecture a
couple times and a few people laughed
yeah the audience actually liked
something I did maybe there's hope and
so I think momentum
I guess grew from there and I felt like
I had a couple of small wins to build on
and
as I got more comfortable I think it
started to go better and then and then
eventually I decided I actually really
enjoy teaching and maybe I would become
decent at it what were you teaching at
the time what were the talks that you
were giving the lectures so I was let's
see the first lecture that I was doing
was it was actually for an intro
psychology class on career choice and I
was I was the worst person in the world
to give this talk because I had no idea
what I wanted to do with my career and
one of the reasons I became a
organizational psychologist was I had
figured out that I could take all the
jobs that I thought were interesting and
I could study those and live and flip
them vicariously and so I still don't
know what I want to do with my life so I
study other people's interesting jobs
but I was I was trying to I guess in the
in the early lectures I was trying to
get students to think about tunnel
vision it's a problem I've seen over and
over again with high achievers you know
I I certainly felt it as an undergrad I
watched a lot of my students at Wharton
go through it since then and I what I
was trying to highlight is that yeah
just because you're highly motivated and
driven and you have you have clarity
about your goals today doesn't mean that
you won't wake up in two years and wish
you had considered other goals and so
you might want to broaden your
peripheral vision a little bit was sort
of a the punchline of the talk so let's
let's dig into broader broadening
peripheral vision or uncovering blind
spots the feedback form I'd love to talk
about the feedback form where the
feedback forms standardized so you
didn't have input into the feedback
forms or were you able to design
questions that you then gave to these
sort of early students / victims of your
many many rehearsals and trial runs and
in either case I'd be curious to know
what you did what you paid attention to
in the feedback forms so actually when I
when I went to give that first guest
lecture I asked the professor you know
if they could give out their standard
feedback forms so I could learn how to
improve and the professor said we guest
lectures don't do feedback forms your
you're donating your time you know your
you're probably pretty comfortable and
confident in having something of value
to offer and you know you know you don't
and then want a bunch of students
telling you why you weren't you weren't
as good as they wanted you to be and you
know if that's not the case you don't
need any more praise anyway and so to
you know nobody really bothers with it
and I said well I really feel it I don't
know what I'm doing I don't know if this
is gonna be a train wreck or just really
bad and so I feel like I have to have to
learn something from the audience and so
I am I just drafted a very simple
feedback it had two questions on it one
was how can I improve and the other was
is there anything I did well that you
know I should try to repeat or or build
on and I remember I actually remember
getting the feedback forums and looking
at them and thinking wow there are a lot
of letters written on the improve
question things I did well question but
what would I think what I took away from
that was I always thought you needed to
be really structured in in the feedback
requests that you make and I think that
sometimes that's helpful right to say
okay you know could you tell me how to
make my talk more interesting or how
could I have kept you awake but that
then I would have been limiting the
feedback to the things I already knew I
needed to work on right and I wanted to
I knew I had blind spots I wanted to to
figure out what those were and so I
think by asking the broad question I got
much more varied feedback and then as I
design future feedback forms I would
always ask those broad questions and
then it follow up with a few targeted
questions on specific things I was
trying to work on what were some of the
things do you recall some of the things
that were specifics you wanted to work
on at any point in your development as a
teacher there's a long list so you know
actually I wondered Tim if you've had
this experience to find teaching way
easier than speaking or lecturing cuz
yep teaching teachings that are active
right you're having a conversation you
get a lot of questions you know
throughout throughout your presentation
and you can very quickly start to figure
out what the audience is interested in
and
Taylor right yeah whereas you know I
think the guest lecturing was with a
little bit of trial by fire because I
had to stand up and perform and I wasn't
I wasn't a skilled or comfortable
performer and so I on it was very simple
things like pausing between sentences
okay occasionally breathing I got I got
feedback at one point that I didn't
blink ever like a barracuda my wife
tells me I still sometimes don't blink
in interviews which which cracks me up
but I was really granular kind of
nuts-and-bolts stage presence and some
of it was content I was I was trying to
I was trying to get students and later
other kinds of audiences to question
their assumptions and I think one of the
things I learned very quickly was I was
attacking their assumptions way too hard
and moment I said you might hate urine
bet investment banking career you might
not fall in love with management
consulting they got defensive and shut
down and so I was working on finding
other ways of of landing at the
conclusion on their terms instead of
mine and saying okay how much do you
really know about Investment Banking is
it possible that if you're not someone
who reads about markets for fun in your
spare time that it's not going to be the
most joyful thing you've ever done to
spend a hundred hours a week in a
spreadsheet so you know a lot of what I
was working on was was just trying to
figure out how to take a message that
was provocative to the audience and make
it palatable you're you're very right I
just want to agree with what you said at
the beginning of that which is teaching
providing much more intermittent
valuable feedback in the sense that when
you're teaching depending on the format
of course but very often confusion
becomes clearer earlier to the teacher
does that make sense if you give up ties
and put and provide a keynote and then
walk offstage the feedback loop if it
exists at all is really slow and kind of
on a macro level but if students if
students can interrupt you they can
raise their hand and say I don't
understand
he's never lose it's so valuable and
also I think you're often in the
position where when you finally finished
your keynote you get to the audience
questions when you're here the first two
questions you realize oh if I'd known
that's what you're interested in
I would have given a completely
different talk yeah definitely and I'm
gonna hop from this to perhaps something
that people listening can model since
some people will be in front of students
but some may not so I'd love to discuss
what I've heard phrased is the challenge
Network and this is from a well it's
Philly mag comm but it's from a profile
from 2018 and and it reads feel free to
fact checks I don't believe everything I
read on the internet but it says he
referring to you literally has a
challenge network in quotation works a
cohort of people he relies on to give
him unvarnished feedback and then the
next part which we'll get to also he
keeps her resume of his failures it's
three pages he constantly asks for
advice on what he could tweak tune up or
totally reconsider what is a challenge
Network and how did you assemble it and
and where I'm reached what I'm reaching
for here is how what did you do and what
might you recommend that other people
also try or at least consider so I guess
I've been I've been doing it for a long
time I didn't have a name for it or
really a structure a formal structure
for it until excited my first podcast
episode where I went to Bridgewater and
it was really interested in in Ray
dahlias you know culture of radical
transparency and I'd studied it for a
few years but this is the first time I'd
really tried to tell the story in audio
as opposed to writing about it and I
went in and I was thinking okay what is
what is different in you know in the
time that I've spent at this place where
you know where people not only are
comfortable with criticism but they
actually seem to enjoy getting it what
what is different about that and I think
at one point it just clicked that they
are trying to build a different kind of
network that we we all know the value of
network but mostly when we think about
networks we're thinking about a support
network which here's the group of
cheerleaders that you surround yourself
with
motivate you to encourage you to you
know to see more potential in you than
you see in yourself and I think that's
incredibly important I think that it's
hard to imagine anyone achieving
anything right without having some kind
of support network behind them you know
whether that's building their confidence
or opening doors for them or helping
them build their skills but Bridgewater
really is about creating a different
kind of network and I feel like what
they have built is a whole company
that's organized around a challenge
Network
where your job is to say look I want you
to be as good as you can be to him so
that means I'm gonna try to tear your
logic apart to see if there any holes in
it and try to improve your reasoning and
your thinking so that you make better
decisions and you come up with with more
compelling solutions to problems and in
a way it's it's a form of tough love
right I think having somebody who's
who's pure challenge and never gives you
any support that just sounds abusive
right but I think you know I think a
great member of a challenge network I'll
tell you about mine is somebody who you
know which is you because they believe
in you and they're not willing to settle
for you know for half-baked ideas or for
something that's not your very best work
if I could just jump in for one second
also for people who don't know
Bridgewater associates just as context
it is perhaps still the largest
certainly one of the largest asset
managers some might call it a hedge fund
with something like a hundred and sixty
billion dollars under management so when
you're deploying that type of capital
and let's just say you're a portfolio
manager or someone making decisions or
at least proposing positions or trades
there are very very real stakes involved
and put you - part of the reason that
I'm so excited to hear about how you
have implemented this or how it's
manifested for you is that you know when
you're dealing with tens or hundreds of
billions of dollars the the consequences
are are perhaps very obvious right and
the incentives are very obvious but in a
few people think of putting together a
challenge Network for themselves so
I love to hear what what that ended up
looking like for you sure so I think
where it actually started when I
transitioned from from doing those guest
lectures to teaching my first class so
I'm a grad student and yes I'm
responsible for teaching a whole
semester long course I remember being so
freaked out for the first class that my
wife actually came and sat in and
pretended to be a TA just just so
afterwards she could tell me that you
know that people were still gonna come
to the next class
I but I got through it and you know we
met twice a week as a class on
organizational change and the students
seem to be genuinely engaged and
enjoying it and you know it it was such
a pleasant surprise coming from the
lecturing to teaching in that way
because I felt like I was building
relationships with them I was getting to
know them I was you know being I was
adjusting the class in real time as I
learned what they wanted to to what they
wanted to learn and so I moved along in
the class I realized that it it was
really easy to focus on things that were
going well because my expectations had
been so low and I needed to figure out
what was going wrong because as a brand
new teacher I was still very nervous I
still did plenty of lecturing in the
class and I was gonna have to teach much
less receptive audiences than a group of
undergrads who signed up for an elective
and so I did I did feedback forms a
couple weeks in and then did something I
guess that was sort of radical I went to
one of my advisers and I said I've
gotten all the feedback from the forums
and there is a lot of real criticism in
there about things that I'm doing very
poorly I was horrible at time management
as an example and a bunch of people said
that you know it'd be really nice if I
ever made it through even 10% of
material I promised at the beginning of
the class so but you know as soon as a
student answered a question I felt like
I had to answer it and so you know just
get sidetracked from well I don't care
what my lesson plan was right I'm here
to serve the students anyway so I went
to my advisor and I said I have all this
feedback and I'm just gonna open source
it I'm gonna share it with the whole
class it's been what are you insane
they're gonna they're gonna band into a
mob of angry Millennials
once they find out that they're all
upset about the same pieces of the class
you know it's gonna be a mutiny don't do
it and I felt like I felt like it was a
it was sort of a crossroads because it
left me wondering who do I want to be do
I wanted do I want to be the the person
who's so determined to prove myself that
I'm afraid of
of students finding out what they
probably already know about me or am I
more interested in improving myself and
I picked the improving route and so I
typed up all the feedback verbatim I
emailed it out to the entire class and
then I devoted a whole class session to
discussing all the suggestions for
improvement and I guess what I've done
was I turned the students a little bit
into my my coaches but it was very much
a challenge Network because their job
was to tell me everything that was not
working about the class and then
brainstorm with me about what we could
do to fix it and so who we spent the it
was funny because the we spent then a
half a semester of a class on
organizational change kind of living an
experiment on how to do organizational
change in the context of the class and
after that experience I said okay I
always want a group of students who are
a challenge Network for me which has men
in some cases when I read a book the
first group that sees the draft of each
chapter is a group of students and their
job is to violently disagree with every
word that I write I try to you know
really try to poke holes in in in
evidence in the logic so they're reading
it like a debate team who has been
assigned to the counter-argument even if
they don't or simply the task of
disassembling your argument even if
that's not how they feel that's the
responsibility that you give them
exactly and so they end up almost
competing to see who can did give the
most devastating criticism I remember
walking into a lab meeting once and a
student said at no point at any time
during reading this chapter did I feel
like I could say the words page-turner
but so that that's it's played out in a
lot of different ways right so when I
was when I was preparing to do my first
TED talk I had a group of people who
watched it and their job was to to argue
with me about all my points
and then you know I've done the same
thing with op-eds and so after I went to
to Bridgewater and the term clicked and
I thought Oh challenge Network that's
what I've been trying to build for
myself I actually reached out to some of
the people that I've relied on the most
in the past decade for that role and
I've said hey I just want you to know
that I consider you a founding member of
my challenge network uh you know I I
know I'm not always as receptive to your
criticism as I would like to be and
sometimes that's probably frustrating
for you but I keep coming to you because
I know I need it and I value it even if
I don't like it and I want you to keep
providing that because that's one of the
central roles that you play in my life
and you've made my work infinitely
better and you know sometimes that's I
feel occasionally that's embolden them
well you know not sure I really needed
that my outfit to be criticized in that
particular talk I gave that's not the
feedback I was looking for it but I
think it's been just immensely
beneficial so Tim I'm curious do you
have a challenge network I have I have
certainly people I rely on to call my
babies or decisions or whatever the
facet of my life might be under scrutiny
ugly when necessary I I definitely do
that it's its clearest when I am
considering a what would be for me a
large decision where I'll call people
just to reality check my thinking I want
them to really spot any weaknesses or
glaring omissions or blind spots that
they see with a bit more distance and
also in writing so I I can't have
cheerleaders as editors at least proof
readers so I will send chapters
typically to very specific people and I
will force their hand a bit because
they're they're all intrinsically quite
nice people but I'll ask them this is
where I think the you know the wording
the questions is so important but for me
I'll ask them if you had to remove say
20% of this chapter which 20% would you
remove gun to the head you have to cut
20% I love that what would you cut and
then I also asked them if you could only
save
10% or 20% depends on the length of the
chapter what what do you think I should
absolutely keep in and the the rule that
I have it's I suppose a more a heuristic
it's not a hard and fast rule but
something that I think about is to
absolutely remove something requires a
consensus of at least two people so if
two people say you should absolutely
remove this I take it very very
seriously to keep something only
requires a vote of one so if five people
respond with five different answers for
this is the 10% I would absolutely 100%
keep in then I do my best to keep all of
that so that would be it that would be
an example I don't have a formal
challenge Network but this is making me
consider doing that and is the challenge
Network your challenge network the the
Bridgewater style challenge Network
something that you involve ad hoc as you
are working on projects and so on or is
it is it something that has a cadence
where you're scheduling like once per
month I'm going to ask XY and Z of these
following four people or once per
quarter I'm going to do a B and C
anything like that is there is there a
structure or a scheduling to it
interesting I think there's a structure
for big projects so when when I'm
reading a book or working on a podcast
these and you know I have a meeting of
my challenge network of students that's
usually once every two weeks and yeah
there's a pretty regular cadence to the
sort of the process of producing
episodes and I know that yeah there's
gonna be new material for them too it's
the trash every every time we come
together I would I love your idea of
saying if you were gonna cut something
what would you cut because I found early
on I felt like you know that they really
let anything that they had in their
heads fly and they weren't too worried
about it and I guess as I've
accomplished more they've been either
more worried that I have a big ego which
is ironic because I think you
accomplished the easier it is to you
know to face a failure and say hey that
doesn't matter I've you know succeeded
in other ways or you know they're just
worried about hurting their relationship
with me and so I've one of the things
found with the regular structure is it's
helpful for me to have a senior student
in there who's worked for me for a long
time or with me for a long time and I'll
actually see the to see it up in advance
and say I want you to come in guns
blazing with the toughest criticism you
could ever give even if you don't fully
believe it
because I want you to model the kind of
challenge that I want and I'm gonna be
prepared prepared for it and I'm gonna
respond as as with as much openness and
you know in curiosity as I can muster
and that way we're gonna try to set the
tone in the norm for you know for the
next few months I'm smart that's what I
think oh yeah it works in in all sorts
of settings group therapy if you want
people to open up I mean there are a lot
of contexts in which that is really
smart that's great I liked that and then
for the for the unstructured I do this
spontaneously a lot so every time I get
off a stage you know you usually
somebody will say oh you know that was
that was great or you know thanks that's
that's not useful to me right so I
always say what's the one thing I can do
better and I've kind of drafted them
against their will into my challenge
Network sometimes they say well you know
nothing and I feel like I have to push
them a little bit and so I've started I
guess I've gotten a little edgier about
this over the past few years and I'll
say huh you know it's funny I thought
you had higher standards than that you
couldn't find a single thing I could
improve on you really think this was
perfect come on and then if it won't
give me anything I will criticize myself
out loud and I'll say look here are the
three things that I think I did poorly
tell me if you agree with any of those
and then what I'm missing and then I've
never had somebody just completely punt
at that point they always offer
something yeah that's great
that's great yeah you you've you're just
giving them permission with more and
more weight pushed behind it why do you
keep a resume of your failures is that
an accurate description of whatever they
were trying to describe in this piece
what is a resume of your failures and
what's the point of it yeah it's
actually an idea I got from a scientist
Melanie Stefan who said look you know we
do such a disservice to to young people
in any field because when they look up
to their role models they only see them
at their peak
when you look at somebody whose resume
or bio and only has their
accomplishments and not all of the
schools that rejected them not all of
the jobs that didn't hike them not all
the creative projects that failed and so
it can be really discouraging if you're
moving into a field to look up at people
who seem perfect and so I just thought
it was a it was a clever way to be
comfortable sharing all the things that
I'd stumbled in and then also it was I
found it I thought it's a good exercise
for me to say you know look it's it's
easy to get caught up in believing that
as you accumulate more success your odds
of success go up over time because you
gain experience you surround yourself
with better people you you know maybe
avoid repeating past mistakes I think
reality is I think that you also take on
more ambitious projects and so in some
ways the odds go down and it was it's
just it's been a reminder to me that
I've rarely ever done anything that
didn't fail radically before I achieved
some success and it it's it's a good I
guess it's a good way to to do a little
bit of mental time travel and say hey
you know what I remember I remember
throwing away a hundred 2,000 words of
my my first draft in my book which was
one hundred three thousand words
and at that moment I felt like I was
never going to write a book and I
couldn't make it as an author and you
know I kind of edited that out of my
story in the way that I think about you
know the process of writing a book
because I moved past that but if I
remember that it's a lot easier to cope
with with today's failure or tomorrow's
very failure how did you decide to do
that 100 2,000 words is a lot of words
for people for people wondering I
suppose if we're talking about like an
average trim size meaning average book
size physical paperback book I'm
probably gonna screw this up a little
bit but a hundred fifty thousand words
would be the length of many books and
that would be let's call it I have no
idea
200 200 to 250 page book or something
like that maybe maybe less um it depends
a lot on the words per page but how did
you decide to like walk me through the
day where you
like this is it I'm scrapping 102,000
words okay I think it was August 2011
and the the lead-up to it I think is is
is important which is I had I decided in
the spring right after I got tenure that
I wanted to start sharing ideas you know
outside of just academia and one of my
favorite collaborators Barry Schwartz
who you probably know from the paradigm
choice talks of choice Barry had
coincidentally reached out and said hey
I'm thinking about writing a book on
motivation and incentives I know you do
a lot work in that area do you want to
write the book together I was so
flattered and it's just seemed like a
great way to begin communicating ideas
and I loved working with him so I had a
meeting with my students that day and
talking about challenge Network they
held me hostage and they told me they
would not let me leave the lab meeting
until I promised him that I wouldn't
write somebody else's book before I
wrote my own I didn't want to let them
down
so I said okay I'll write my book and
then maybe one day Barry and I will do
something together again and so I went
through the whole process to find a
literary agent and had Richard pine come
in as my agent and he said write a
proposal after we talked about a bunch
of ideas I started working on the
proposal in June and I got so into it
that I accidentally wrote the book for
people listening that doesn't generally
happen continued here's how it happens
right so because 2011 I am reading a
book about a topic I've been studying
for a decade I've been living it and
breathing it and I have so many thoughts
and ideas about it and I never really
sat down to organize them and so you
know I start to write about a study and
that then that calls to mind three other
studies that I love and then that
reminds me of a story that I think will
illustrate the study in an interesting
way and so it just it just became I mean
it's it's literally all I did for that
summer like what's right to draft in the
book and so I sent it to Richard in
August he had actually kicked in and
said hey where's that proposal that said
oh it's a little long because I think I
have a draft of the book and Richard
being a great member
my challenge Network said I got to be
honest with you I don't even know if
your academic colleagues would finish
reading this book that was after he sent
after you sent him rather the draft
correct I don't actually think he made
it through the draft it was so bad but
you know it's basically like reading a
hundred research paper strung together
and academic research papers are not
they're not interesting for the most
part so he he gave me some great advice
no he said he said just do me a favor
don't write like you write journal
articles write like you teach and that
was a lightbulb moment for me and so it
kind of turned around from this is
agonizing I think I will never be an
author to okay if I were gonna if I were
gonna tell the story of these ideas in
the classroom what would I do and then I
actually I started I started doing the
talk out loud so that I wouldn't go back
into the trap of academic writing and I
found that it was way easier to write
about other people's ideas than my own
and so I decided I was gonna lead my
ideas out of the first couple of
chapters RAF's and just write about
other people's stuff as if I were
introducing it to my students with the
same excitement that I would in a
classroom and that I found a lot of that
felt really familiar and comfortable and
then from there the the second chapter
was better i resuscitated about a
thousand words from the first draft and
will never show the other one hundred
two thousand to anyone Wow yeah I
thought I thought it was hard throwing
away four chapters two or three times my
first book one hundred and two thousand
words is a lot or one hundred one
thousand excuse me you've said earlier
about your getting diverted during class
and not following lesson plans as
reflective of you being horrible at time
management now based on the bio and the
it seems aw with which many of your
colleagues certainly people with sort of
within your world
outside of your world experience with
looking at all of these accomplishments
how what would how would your good
friends the people who really know you
explain your ability to get things done
well first we have the pot calling the
kettle black here Tim I was really
amused when you texted me and said you
were gonna hustle so that we could start
early because I literally don't think
you were capable of not hustling well we
need to we need to get into the nuances
of hustle but I I have two speeds I've
park and six gear there's really very
there's very there's very little in
between that is true but you're even
you're even intense about your Park yeah
there is there's a certain baseline
intensity I will not deny I will not
that but but but you you and I have also
played an in some similar sandboxes but
also a lot of very different sand boxes
I think I've cheated in the sense that I
have have kind of rigged games and and
loaded decks of cards so that I can sort
of freestyle my way through whatever
this is that I have ended up calling a
career but you within the seemingly very
well-established constraints of the
academic world and research world have
done things that seem to defy belief
that's a lot harder
there are rules and norms right you I
what I had to do is exist I had to go
into somebody else's system and figure
out how to succeed within it you had to
create your own system I think that's
way harder but we could we can duke that
out later try to answer your question
how would your if it allows you to speak
more directly to it because I you know
it's it's not always easy to kind of pat
yourself on the back and that's that's
not what I'm aiming for here but you are
an outlier
and I think objectively speaking you are
an outlier so how would people who
really know you explain the factors the
behaviors that have contributed to that
so I've asked a bunch of people that
question got tired of saying I don't
know I just work a lot I guess when it
when it came up and I think there are
there are a few things that I've learned
that I didn't know were may be useful
habits that I guess I either do
instinctively or at some point decided
were effective so the my college
roommates used to tell me that I that I
had a productive form of mild air CD and
the I guess they saw it when I was I was
writing my my undergrad thesis and I
think I finished it four months before
it was due because I I just woke up in
the morning and I would write until I
had said everything I had to say and
yeah I'd rarely get up out of my chair
and you know sometimes I would go to
lunch but I think I I really I hate
leaving something unfinished and so this
is this is actually both a blessing and
a curse so the blessing is it means that
you know and I said time to start
something I will finish it what that
means is whatever else was on my agenda
after that is just going haywire so I'm
constantly late because I have a chronic
inability doing to disengage from the
current thing on my agenda to you know
to go and move on to the next thing
right and time is sort of an arbitrary
human construction well I didn't know
yesterday when I scheduled this meeting
that I was going to be in flow today at
this time yeah I hope this person values
our collaboration enough or you know is
is glad to be able to you know to yell
at me about always being late enough
that they're willing to put up with it
but I think that for me that's I think
I'm bad at time management but I'm I've
gotten good at attention management and
I just when I sit down I know as a
psychologist we have decades of evidence
that people are horrible parallel
processors mm-hmm all right we're serial
processors it's really not just in the
multitasking sense
but in the course of a morning you're
not going to be that productive if
you're trying to work on five different
things and so what I try to do is I try
to do one project or task at a time
until you know I've either gotten as far
as I can go with it and I've run out of
ideas or I've physically run out of time
that I can't work on it anymore and I
find I find it that's useful and what
that means sometimes is I'm in a meeting
one of my colleagues who I asked okay
you know is there anything I do that
that's productive that I don't realize
is productive and she said yeah we're in
a meeting we've got seven minutes left
and we've just finished a task and I'll
just start chit-chatting and she said
what'd you do I guess what I learned
what I do is I'll say well we've got
another task that we could at least
start in those seven minutes and so we
end up using those extra minutes but
also then the meeting stretches 20
minutes over because then we got into a
rhythm and we got a little bit more done
and I think that that people are way too
rigid about respecting time boundaries
as opposed to saying look you know you
if you're all if you're all about time
management then you're just gonna you're
gonna just notice how much time you
waste and then you're gonna waste more
time beating yourself up about how much
time you waste time waster I really
believe in the idea of attention
management instead which is to say that
you know if I am if I'm choosing people
and projects that matter to me it does
not matter how long they take and so I
have a project I want to work on today
and you know whatever it's done it'll be
done but I'm excited to be working on it
and I'm not gonna pick up anything else
until I feel like I've made meaningful
progress on it and I don't know if
that's useful now you tell me did I say
anything novel there well I yes you did
I think there are a few things to look
at here and I don't want to take us down
a dead-end but you what I'm what I'm
trying to splice out are the trainable
habits from perhaps hardwiring or
attributes that are not as easy to model
right yeah the so the the OCD right this
OCD I guess
haha we don't have to get into it but
the dark side of Nintendo if that rings
any bells
this is I'll just I'll just give the
short versions so there's a there's yeah
in the Detroit Free Press there is a an
article that was headlined the dark side
of Nintendo with a photograph of you
aged seven clutching a Nintendo console
and staring at a television but you've
had this this extreme ability to focus
for some time it would seem the the
attention management versus time
management I think is really important
and something I'd like to explore a bit
because but you're right in the sense
that time management can end up becoming
a subconscious obsession with measuring
units as opposed to the substance of the
project or the output goal of some type
of task right and what I'd love to hear
about is I I really think renegotiation
is a critical skill in all human affairs
but you alluded to this earlier in the
sense that if there are times many times
when it's hard to predict when you'll be
in flow and the information that you
then have that day is different from the
information you have the day before when
you made commitments a B and C right so
how do you say no to people well you've
already said yes how do you renegotiate
or cancel these commitments when you
realize that you want to do something
else you're out of bandwidth or whatever
the reason might be how do you approach
that well my my first goal is always to
minimize the number of times that
happens mm-hm and so I read some
research early on about the difference
between chunking and sprinkling as I've
come to think about it so the research
was on doing random acts of kindness
this is Sonia [ __ ] mercy and her
colleagues and the idea was let's
imagine 10 that you're gonna do five
5-minute favors this week you if your
if you're randomly assigned to sprinkle
you're gonna do one each day throughout
the week if you're gonna Chunk you're
gonna pick Thursday as you're helping
day and you're gonna do all five of them
stacked in that one day it a block and
the question is who gets happier and
more energized and when I pose this to
audiences about 80% of people on average
say it's the sprinkling because you know
you get a little bit of extra bounce in
your step you feel like you did
something good every day it's not a big
distraction and they're totally wrong
over over about three months only one
group gets happier and more energized is
actually the chunker's not the
sprinklers and we think we think what's
going on there it's this is still pretty
early but it's been replicated a few
times now both in the workplace and and
in volunteering is when when you do one
little act of giving a day you end up
sort of feeling like it's a drop in the
bucket and it also you notice yet
another thing on your to-do list whereas
when you pick one day each week as your
giving day you feel like you made a
difference that day and also you're
really focused on okay what can I do to
help these people in those moments and
so and then you know the rest of the
week you can you can focus a little bit
more on getting your own work done and
so I I took that to my schedule and said
alright I'm gonna have days that are
focused on getting my own creative work
done and then I'm gonna have days that
are focused on being responsive and
available for other people and so early
on that man I would have days where I
was on campus and I would have I would
teach a class and then I would have four
hours of office hours back-to-back and
then I do whatever else I needed one and
then I go home and then the next day I
wouldn't go into work and I work from
home all day and I would now talk to
another human being who wasn't a member
of my family and that's kind of how I've
tried to organize my life and what it
means is Paul Graham wrote a great
little blog post about this he called
the maker days and manager days it means
I don't feel like I'm that productive
you know when I'm on campus or I'm in a
back-to-back meeting day but it also
means then that on the day when I'm
doing creative work there's nothing
that's gonna interrupt my flow because
I'm not scheduling anything that you
know that might distract and so I think
prevention is always the best cure there
but you wanted to know about also what
happens when that fails
correct so when that fails I had this
happened actually recently I had agreed
to to travel and give a speech and I
ended up having a conflict with a
project that I had committed to earlier
but didn't know the dates for and I felt
awful I it's it's a core principle for
me to follow throughout my commitments
and I'd never I've never reneged on a
speech like that before and so I reached
out to the organizer I apologized
profusely and I said you have my word
that I'm gonna recruit someone far
better than me so that you will be
thrilled that I cancelled and then I
made it my mission to find somebody who
would either hit a more relevant topic
or who was going to give a more
electrifying presentation and then just
to be safe I recruited three more
speakers for the event because I was
really worried that I was still letting
them down and that that for me is is the
only renegotiation strategy I ever feel
comfortable with which is to say look my
calendar has gotten the better of me or
I've over extended myself yet again and
so I promise you that the time you have
lost today I will make up for it in
spades for you tomorrow like that now
how do you just ah ha I'll answer that
I'll answer that Libby I'm also learning
so I'm fishing for tactics here but
would you use that also how would that
wording change if it's a is a meeting
with a colleague
so something where there is no replacing
of yourself for a future engagement this
that how would the wording potentially
change understanding that you try not to
do it yeah but let's just say you're
writing a book you're on deadline and
that chapter you've been stuck on all of
a sudden you're in complete flow and for
whatever reason it's it's not it's it's
on a day where there's there's there's a
commitment that has been made I hate
being irreplaceable in that sense but I
I guess I would so I've I've had that
happen I guess that's a happens at least
a few times a year and what I've usually
done is I've you know they're called the
person and said I've tried to email
actually because it's less likely to
disrupt my flow and I've said look I'm
really sorry I've had something come up
I know you were counting on me to be
here I'm not going to be able to make it
what you can count on me for is always
delivering results and so you may not
always get the FaceTime that I promised
you may not always get me to show up
exactly at the moment I said I was going
to be there I will never miss the
deadline I will never fail to deliver
something I promise to you when you need
it and so you let me know what your hard
stop is and I will stay up as late as I
need to tonight to finish what I need to
do if you want to hop on the phone early
in the morning I will be on the phone
with you and so I guess I'm trying to
find a way to to let the person know
that I am dependable for the outcome
even though I was not dependable
necessarily for the interaction that's
great yeah that makes a whole lot of
sense and you and me it's it's very
context-specific I think as these
examples bring up there are some meta
principles right I think the the meta
principle is make up for it right to say
like you are causing some pains what can
you do to remove that pain or make them
feel on some level that you are going
above and beyond to make up for what was
lost I think for me a lot of it is being
very honest and just saying like when I
made the commitment I wholeheartedly
felt like I would be able to do a B and
C it is become clear based on new
information or a B C and D that if I
make an attempt to do this let's just
say that this is kind of broadly
speaking that I think at best I am going
to do a mediocre job because of the
limited bandwidth I'm going to have and
that would be a disservice to project X
or everything that both of us were
hoping for for this let me find a
replacement I would like to find a
replacement
something along those lines I like that
yeah and it's what I try not to do is
sorry I can't do this right now ask me
again in three months unless I genuinely
believe that it is something I want to
do because the hunt the punting is a
huge [ __ ] you to the person you're
interacting with it's it's it's much
better to give a hard no than a maybe
that in your heart of hearts is actually
a no so that that I really try to avoid
by all means necessary I and I wish I'd
learned that a few years earlier hard
way yeah yeah it creeps up on you that
is just like the creeping death and it's
bad for everybody and I what I also have
tried to remind myself of I think a lot
of the renegotiating that I do and I've
done a lot more of it in the last few
years is not because I could purchase Li
make more commitments but because things
do change if I commit to do something
and let's just say it's six months out
and there's still plenty of room to
maneuver and life circumstances change I
used to come hell or high water say my
word is my bond you're only as good as
your word I'm going to follow through on
everything I initially commit to but
I've I've come to rethink that and it
doesn't mean people can't depend on me
people can depend on me to be very
truthful about changes in circumstances
and what I've noticed for myself because
I have people do this to me as well who
are very very busy and they just for
whatever reason they can't go on a trip
with me or they can't help with whatever
the project might be is that I don't get
particularly I don't get upset I don't
get upset unless they leave me hanging
last-minute because I know they didn't
just figure it out last-minute they knew
probably weeks before right so as long
as they give me a heads-up I don't get
upset
so the Ted Geisel aka dr. Seuss quote
you know those who matter don't mind and
those who mind don't matter is something
I really try to remind myself of because
when you say no whether it's an initial
no or
renegotiate it no assuming you're doing
it with plenty of time and you're not
really leaving someone hanging is
something you can control but you can't
you have you have no control over the
other side's response that's it that's
more of a reminder and self-talk that I
use for myself in the circumstances
because I do think that the the tactics
you're able to deploy are dependent
largely on the beliefs you have and if
the belief you have is every
relationship is equally important and if
I burn any bridge I'm screwed you're
gonna make a lot of compromises that
have a huge impact on your ability to
steer your own direction it's it's true
and Tim this makes me think it's it's
interesting it seems like you you had a
really sort of literal definition of
integrity early on and over time you've
you've been more comfortable saying look
I'm gonna be authentic and you know
sometimes that means past him did not
calibrate well with the present Tim you
know there's a commitment made then no
longer makes sense and I'm gonna I'm
gonna try to make that right however I
can
I wonder there's there's all this
research on behavioral integrity which
says that you know you're you're
basically supposed to practice what you
preach and I've been wondering lately if
we've got that backward and if instead
what we should be doing is only
preaching things that we already
practice hmm and then we don't have as
many of those gaps you're not you're not
the bit the behavioral Greyhound chasing
around the sort of theoretical bunny
yeah yeah that makes a lot of sense to
me
and let's let's talk a little bit more
about no and in saying no because and
and we'll get there in a bit of a
roundabout way perhaps I'd like to just
discuss you a piece you rode in the New
York Times about email yeah let's talk
about it
so I and it starts with no you can't
ignore email it's
[Music]
that okay so you didn't write that line
somebody else did but the maybe you
could I'll let you speak for yourself
you share you share your thesis and when
it applies and when it doesn't apply I
feel like that head lives ruined more
good op eds then I can count right yeah
yeah I okay so the reason the reason I
wrote this piece is I read two articles
back-to-back one in the Atlantic one in
the New York Times that basically said
you know what forget inbox zero just go
to inbox infinity and you don't ever
have to respond to anybody's email and I
was stunned by that because I thought
okay would you if somebody said hi to
you in the hallway would you just ignore
them somebody somebody called you would
you never return their voicemail that
you know that that seems unprofessional
and so what makes digital snobbery okay
and you know I started think about the
research on this and there's there's a
whole bunch of evidence suggesting that
all the personality traits that matter
for job performance whether we look at
your objective productivity is a sales
person there or an engineer or your
performance reviews and promotions that
you get from your manager the single
most important personality trait across
hundreds and hundreds of jobs and dozens
of countries around the world is
conscientiousness right being being
hard-working organized discipline
dependable and there's a there's a
component of conscientiousness that's
about being responsive which says two
things one I'm on top of things and two
I care and so I'm not look I'm not
saying you have to answer every email
that every random person sends you right
now this is this is complicated for a
lot of jobs but I think that if you are
habitually not responding to legitimate
emails from people that you have a
professional relationship with it is
sending a signal to them that you are
either disorganized or that you don't
care about their priorities and people
are constantly saying well wait a minute
but but hold on but you know my inbox is
other people's priorities
and my response to that is yeah but
shouldn't your priorities include other
people and also don't you want people to
respond to your emails and so you know I
just I felt like it was time for
somebody to write the counterpoint and
so I sat down and I said look I think
that if you are you know a consistent
non-responder to serious emails that
suggests that there's a problem with
your process and you need a different
way of handling it if you want if you
care about being perceived as you know
as somebody who's responsible and
reliable and concerned about others
which is really important for your
success
even if you don't care about your image
so that was the motivation behind it
what are some of your processes for
email how do you how do you process
email do you have do you have any
particular rules x approaches anything
at all tools that that you that you use
consistently yeah I have actually Tim I
read you you you gave fantastic advice
about this I remember right after her
give-and-take came out I just got a
deluge of emails from from readers and I
read a blog post that you wrote about
how to be more efficient with email and
one of the first things I saw in there
was we were talking about Tony Shay's
yester box which I tried out and found
really useful you know just just the
habit of going and saying okay so I can
answer all of yesterday's email today I
will never fall behind amazing I do a
lot of batch processing so you know I I
try to I'm not somebody who will just
you know kind of randomly answer one
email I will sit down and try to go
through 30 or 40 or a hundred emails and
I think I'd break one of the cardinal
rules that most of the writers I know
have with email which is on my writing
days I actually deliberately start in
the morning by answering a few emails
why is it well it's simple I want to get
into a rhythm of writing and the
flashing cursor it's just it's so honest
like that I liked it a lot
yeah like that I actually found myself
curious a couple of months ago and I was
trying to write an article and and yeah
kind of mini writer's block think
like huh wonder if the cursor was named
after all the writers who cursed us and
it's just you know it's really daunting
right it feels like okay I have to say
something important I have to have a
grand idea I have to you know have to be
coherent I just woke up
and so emails a low bar and so I feel
like okay my fingers start moving I get
into you know a little bit of a
productive rhythm and I answer a few
easy emails and I feel like I've
accomplished something today maybe maybe
I can organize a coherent thought then
you know that that spills over and
builds my confidence and gives me a
little momentum for my writing do you
use Gmail do you have any tools that you
use for going through email
I'm embarrassingly Luddite on this even
though everyone I know and trust has
told me to switch to superhuman I am
still using outlook without any
shortcuts mm-hmm will you still talk to
me after knowing that I will I will
still I will still consider future
conversations I actually I you know if I
can admit something embarrassing I
actually quite like outlook yes for some
of its functionality there are a lot of
tools out there that I think are quite
helpful but I do quite like outlook and
in fact I you a lot of my batch
processing with Gmail offline because
the split pane view that I can use is
actually reminiscent both in appearance
but also functionality to outlook and
and I don't want to receive emails as I
am replying to emails
that's the worst it's to demotivate
how do you say no I in an email and you
could give any the there they may not be
one no for all occasions but what is if
someone gets a no from Adam
what what might that look like so that
and what what are they asking for and
what do you say no to are there anything
anything is categorically that you say
no to yeah definitely I don't take
meetings with strangers
period I used to take meetings with
anyone who asked and I guess as I've
gotten more visible there just aren't
enough hours in the day for it and I had
to decide I prioritized I said my family
comes first my students are second my
colleagues and friends are third and
everybody else is fourth and you know
that that meant that okay
I'll happily respond to an email from a
stranger if it's reasonable and it's up
my alley and you know but I just don't
have enough hours in the day to meet
with people that I don't have a an
existing reason to be collaborating with
or trying to help and so that that's a
categorical No and one thing I will
never say is I don't have time that is a
lie everybody makes time for something
that's important no and so what I don't
have time really means or I'm too busy
that's even worse right everybody's busy
the busiest people I know have they
often the clearest calendars you've
written about this before you've written
about how Warren Buffett and Bill Gates
and George Lucas and others they
basically have nothing scheduled all day
which is kind of an amazing life but I
think that I think too busy is is
dishonest and cruel and what you what
you really mean when you say that is
this or you are not a priority for me
right now and so I've tried I think that
sounds a little harsh and so the way
that I will try to say it is you know
based on the commitments that I have on
my plate this is not something that I
can add mmm-hmm and then what what I'll
try to do is is suggest either some
books or articles to read or some people
who might be interested in having that
discussion that's that's probably they
go to response
yeah that's great do you have an auto
response of any time yeah I have so have
an auto reply that comes to my public
email address and I made the decision
about I guess yeah I was right after
giving take him out when my email volume
increased exponentially I said okay I
have a choice I can either maintain a
public email address and accept the fact
that I will not be as thoughtful and
responsive to every person as I have
been the rest of my life or I'm going to
be unreachable and I'm going to miss out
on opportunities to be helpful to random
people
and I felt like the it would have been
better for me to go to the private route
and you know be a little bit harder to
reach but I felt like the right thing to
do was to still be accessible and just
okay so if it hurts my image a little
bit that's it's a small price to pay and
so I'm a public email address though the
the I guess the attempt to protect
myself is an auto-reply
that basically says you know look I have
I do get more emails in a day then I
have the time to respond to and here are
a bunch of resources that might be
relevant depending on the kinds of
questions that you have so there are
various teams that handle different
things for me there are some you know
links to books and podcasts and articles
and talks and then I have a triage team
that works with me where if there's
something that I think we can
collectively be helpful on but I don't
have time to engage with it in that
moment I will forward it and let it and
figure it out and then come back and
tell me if they think I can be helpful
what would an example of a triage team
task be and how what is their what does
their activity look like so what would
be a real or hypothetical example of
something you would send to them and
then what do they actually do with it so
I'll give you a bunch of quick examples
you tell me which one you want to run
with that's standard triage I'm looking
for career advice I am interested in
becoming an organizational psychologist
and I wonder what the the best place to
start is I am thinking about writing a
book what advice do you like to give to
writers are these all from students
they're from all over them all over the
mat probably similar to what you get
mm-hmm okay
and any others I can pick from those or
no I can rattle off a bunch more yeah
let's try a few more can can you can you
help me solve my problem with my boss
can you fix my organizational culture
can you get me a raise you know I think
that's funny for yeah go ahead let's
let's go with can you fix my
organizational culture no no okay I got
it no it's I mean it's hard right so
what I would do in that situation is if
you know if somebody wrote me a 9 page
that would just forward it right to
triage if it were a two paragraph email
I might respond and say you know here
are my two favorite books on the topic
are switched by the heath brothers and
the culture code by Dan Coyle you I
think there's a lot of great great
advice in there if you read anything and
have questions on it let me know or if
there if you have questions on things
that they didn't answer come back to me
and I'll suggest some other books to
check out and if it goes to the triage
team what they will do is they might
send a bunch of advice and articles and
books they might suggest a phone call or
they might come back to me and say we're
not really sure how to respond to this
do you know anyone else that we should
talk to the triage team are those
comprised of students laves or are those
full-time full-time employees who are
these people I need to ask triage no
it's I've worked with a couple of a
couple different structures for it so
sometimes it's a person who who works
with me in a different capacity who then
does triage as a side project sometimes
it's a it's a masters or a PhD student
who's who's doing this you know kind of
in in spare time and I think in one case
it actually maybe in two cases it's
somebody who's aspiring to go to grad
school in my field and wants to see
behind the scenes mm-hmm the reason I
chose the can you fix your
organizational cultures because it's
it's the only one that hopped out as a
broad question that might have an
opportunity hiding in it for yeah
compared to the others such as curious
about how how that might be treated how
do you decide what's important in the
sense that you have many many many
different projects you could focus on
many many different books you could
write many many different people you
could you could meet how do you decide
on projects I mean I figure that yeah
maybe we could do it it might be easiest
with the rearview mirror in the sense
that you can look at a project and say
how did you of the unit
of options yeah why did you choose that
one so okay so two two quick examples on
that one is after give-and-take came out
I I felt like I was ready to start
thinking about a new topic and ready a
new book and I felt like a book was a
good choice for a few reasons one I feel
like unlike articles it actually has
staying power right I think that room
I'm not sure that the pen is mightier
than the sword but I definitely think
the ink lasts longer you know I think
art articles kind of fade after a week
people keep books they reread them
they'll end them so I felt like that was
meaningful and I also felt like it was a
chance to to challenge my own my own
thinking a little bit I found that when
I wrote give and take I actually learned
more about the topic that studying then
then I had when just doing research on
it because it forced me to synthesize
lots of different kinds of ideas and
also to go and meet people who are
living the principles I've been studying
so I wanted to go through that learning
exercise again and the way that I chose
what the topic was gonna be was I paid
attention to the questions I was being
asked over and over again that I thought
were really fascinating and important
and hard to answer and there were two
they kept coming up over and over again
one was from senior executives who are
consistently asking how do I fight
groupthink how do I you know I know
there are people who have different
ideas for projects we should be pursuing
people who have creative thoughts people
who might disagree with a big strategic
decision and I don't hear from them
until it's too late how do I change that
and then on the flip side my students
were giving me their version of that
which was we come into an organization
at 22 or 27 and we have all these ideas
and nobody above us wants to hear like
you MBA student you are overqualified
and under experience shut up until you
know something about this industry how
do we ever come back and get our ideas
hear heard and I realized those were two
sides of the same coin that and and that
you know nobody had there were lots of
books about creativity nobody had really
tackled the question of of what do you
do after you have a creative idea how do
you champion it how do you get it heard
and I had I've been doing some research
on unpro activity and creativity that
was relevant and that those dots all
connected
I said okay there's a there's a nice
Venn diagram here of a problem that
people are dealing with constantly that
really matters and that I also have some
sort of unique insight into and so I
want to take this on and for you how do
you how do you determine if a project
like that has succeeded or failed I want
to hear your answer to this I this is
one of the worst things about being an
entrepreneur of ideas as opposed to
products or services right like user
counts are not that helpful it doesn't
it doesn't matter how many books you
sold if nobody read them and I won't
name any names here but there there is
probably an economist who sold a lot of
books about inequality that I'm not sure
anyone read you wonder does that have an
impact you don't know for me impact is
seeing the ideas getting embedded in
people's language and then in their
actions and so you know for for me part
of the way that I felt give-and-take had
been more successful than I then I
expected going in was I would come into
an organization and it would tell me who
the givers takers and matchers were or
they would tell me how they were trying
to weed out the the most selfish takers
from their hiring process Wow
wow this is this is in your vocabulary
that means I think so much what I do as
a social scientist is I try to provide a
framework and some evidence to describe
things that maybe you've you've lived
but not known how to talk about and so
if that happens that's powerful and then
of course if behavior change happened
that's even more powerful but it's
really hard to know the scale and scope
of sad and so you know largely I think
anecdotally I pay attention to you know
yes you know suddenly more books is
probably better than fewer having more
thoughts listeners is better than fewer
but ultimately it's it's reader feedback
listener feedback that you know somebody
says hey I tried your approach it worked
or I tried it it didn't work but here's
what I learned it feels like it you know
it at least advanced somebody's thinking
and that that feels like a contribution
you've been at this a lot longer than I
have you've also had a lot more success
how do you know when you're when you're
successful or when you've had an impact
good question
I'll tell you what I try to do and that
is to select projects where I win even
if it fails and is a so I really try to
embed the success question into the
design or selection of the project and
I'll explain what I mean by that this is
reflective of thinking that I arrived at
myself it's also been been talked about
at some length by Scott Adams the
creator of Dilbert who has written about
this in the form of career advice which
I thought was really good and which was
also Scott Adams essays at one point
were highlighted by Marc Andreessen very
well known entrepreneur and investor
certainly and the basic idea is that I'm
I try to choose projects where I am
heavily waiting two things one is
acquisition of new skills development of
new skills or just the rapid development
of existing skills and developing
relationships with people I can know for
10 20 years and would enjoy spending
time with who are also some of the best
people in the world at what they do yeah
I try to this might seem like a dodge
but it's not a dodge because over time
at least I've realized how many factors
that could dictate say commercial
success which in is is often a corollary
to impact in terms of the number of
hands you can get into the number of
eyes you can get in front of for
instance the 4-hour chef I mean by far
the hardest book the most elaborate book
the most detailed book I've ever done
very proud of that book but it was also
a gamble which I knew going in because
it was the the first book announced
along with the launch of Amazon
publishing in the New York Times and or
I should say covered by the New York
Times
and for those who don't remember the
history what that meant was Amazon said
for the first time in effect we are
going to compete with publishers for
writing talent and we are gonna write
advances in some cases big advances to
authors and we are going to be producing
books ourselves and that's scared the
living hell rightfully so out of the
publishing establishment and I
anticipated that with me and blowback
from Barnes & Noble I did not anticipate
that it would be boycotted by every
retailer you can imagine I mean I want
to say Target Costco Walmart all of the
big-box guys in addition to the Barnes
and Nobles of the world and independence
on top of that so the there were so many
so many elements outside of my control
and I found that experience to be really
punishing I was i've never with a book
had my ass handed to me so badly not not
to point fingers because we both have
friends at the New York Times but the
the New York Times bestseller list is
not a strictly compiled by the numbers
list there is some secret sauce or at
least a black box involved so for
instance with with 4-hour chef I sold
more than 100,000 copies in week one and
it was and I'm not going to name names
because they were all so that the the
books involved were very good but there
was a book that according to Nielsen
Bookscan which is how I was tracking my
sells sold about 20,000 copies and it
was two spots above me on the New York
Times and so all of this whether it's
subjectivity and or factor factors
outside of my control led me at that
point to really double down on trying to
embed the determinants of success in the
designer choice of the project
I think that's projects themselves
that's so compelling because
what it says to me is you decided that
learning and relationship building are
the two leading indicators of success
but also there were the ends in and of
themselves and so even if they don't
drive success you're still gonna be glad
you invested in something that that sort
of formed a meaningful connection or
taught you something that that is such a
clever workaround problem of do I do I
know whether I'm accomplishing anything
yeah it uh it's I wish I had come to
that conclusion sooner quite frankly
because the if you approach things with
that lens at least in my experience so
far eventually you're gonna win I as as
measured or determined by the outside
world if that makes sense right it's
like you continue to acquire skills and
deep relationships with people you care
for who are also incredibly good at what
they do you will this success cannot be
kept from you indefinitely and if it
weren't for the 4-hour chef and that
incredible learning experience but also
gigantic donkey kick to the face I would
not have started podcasting right and we
it wouldn't have happened and that it
was through the 4-hour chef and looking
for the uncrowded meaning undervalued
but high leverage avenues for promotion
which ended up being podcasts I do that
for every book and in that particular
case podcasts were still very
undervalued and that led me to have
these incredible experiences on the on
the on these various podcasts with Joe
Rogan and Marc Maron and Chris Hardwick
and the Nerdist guys and so on and came
away thinking wow not only did these
podcasts really move the needle in a way
that was so disproportionate based on
how undervalued they were at the time
but I also had a hell of a good time
doing them and I could be yourself and I
didn't have to memorize a twenty second
sound by
after getting my face airbrushed for an
hour at five o'clock in the morning for
a am TV show there maybe I will be asked
a question that isn't read off a
teleprompter behind my head but maybe
not and that was a real turning point
for me and it innit
some grateful for it and you know that
that's been that's been my approach
since anyway sorry for being so long
long-winded but that's that's how I
think about it I think that's powerful
and it's it's something it resonates a
lot with me because I I got into the
podcast world much later than you did
and felt like it was by that point
pretty crowded and yeah there are a lot
of interesting people having interesting
conversations and so I was pretty
hesitant about it at first and then
eventually said okay my biggest problem
is I have spent the past five years
getting invited into some of the most
interesting organizations on earth and
telling them things I already know
mostly I'm not learning anymore and so
even if the podcast completely fails I'm
going to pick the people in the places
that I want to learn from and then I'm
gonna come away with new insights on the
back end that in some format I will
share and it it was extremely valuable I
mean it gave me all kinds of ideas for
articles and books and for research
projects I wanted to take on and it
would it would have been great even if
we didn't do a season two and beyond and
I think that I think you're right I
think there there are ways to structure
new projects so that even if they don't
achieve conventional success you still
gain more than you invested in them yeah
definitely and speaking of learning you
mentioned two books earlier switch and
the culture code I think they were all
right what other books have you gifted
the most to other people besides your
own of course here's this thing I wrote
you do a bunch of work and I jest as
opposed to if you know each other maybe
you should just we can just talk about
it right
we're just screwing with you you know it
makes me think of I don't know if you've
seen what about Bob class fantastic
women he was like there's this
groundbreaking new book out Bob let me
let me find it here and he drags his
finger back and forth on the Shelf which
has like a hundred copies of his own
book and he goes hi yes here it is I was
a speaker at a Google event a few years
ago and a bunch of people just went way
too far and stuff promoting their books
and it was it was over the top and I I
got up there ditched my slides and I
about halfway through my talk I said all
right I've got to tell you if you really
want to understand what motivates people
you have to read this incredible book
which I wrote sarcastic or that snarky
but I just felt like somebody needed to
acknowledge the elephant in the room
never recommend my own book right so to
your question what if I gifted the most
I've got it I've got a few favorites so
you know I think I tend to gift
mostly in the genre that I write in so
you know thinking about big ideas that
are evidence-based that can improve the
way we work in live and so mistakes were
made but not by me is the favorite you
know I'm sure you know that bite a
virgin Aaronson a great book on why we
are egos get in the way and just about
everything and how to overcome that I've
gifted Susan Cain's book quiet more
times than I can count
and interestingly I started out gifting
it to introverts thinking okay this is
gonna be a book that shows you all of
your strengths and the ways you're not
alone in the world and you know it
certainly spoke to me that way this is
an introvert and I have to tell you the
the biggest fans of that book from my
experience are actually extroverts who
say oh you know I need to embrace my
quieter side and I need to make more
room for the quiet people around me
because I'm missing out on their
brilliance so that's I think that's
always fun and it's especially fun to
give that book to an engineer who has
never heard of introversion extroversion
and it's a giant light bulb I actually
had
student early on who read it and said oh
my gosh my boyfriend isn't boring he's
just an introvert that's another
favorite and then I have it's a newer
book so I haven't haven't been able to
gift it as many times yet but I've
recommended a lot recently that if
people want to want to figure out what
their what their biggest blind spots are
that one of the things they ought to do
is spend a little bit of time reading
Tasha Eirik spoke on self-awareness and
asked I think it's called the insight
and the insight that I took away from it
was that people who are really
self-aware don't spend a lot of time
agonizing over why they are the way they
are they don't they don't find it that
productive I guess I've never found it
that productive 2-cycle anima analyze
myself why did I why did I get the way I
am I don't know there could be a million
biogenetic and life experience factors
it doesn't really matter here's how I am
and then how do I work with that to be
effective and live a life of meaning and
I think it was a it was a really cool
book on on how to become more aware of
what your strengths and weaknesses are
do you know how to spell the author's
name yeah Tasha ta sha and then Urich u
RI CH I believe cool I will I will find
it and put it in the show notes for
everyone yes not you RI CH there it is
hey I got also available on audio for
people who are interested subtitled the
surprising truth about how others see us
how we see ourselves and why not that's
all I can see I'll put that in the show
notes
yeah blind spots what a thing and how do
you are there any other tools or
questions you asked yourself or have
other people prompted with to help you
further find your blind spots yeah so
what
things I learned about actually doing a
podcast episode on on your hidden
personality I went to Bain
the consulting firm in part because they
spend a lot of time building brand new
teams where people who have know nothing
about each other have to go into you
know often in their 20s into very senior
executives offices and tell them how to
run their companies and they they have a
lot riding on whether these brand new
teams can interact smoothly and so they
not surprisingly put a lot of energy
into figuring out okay you know what are
the the traits and strengths and
weaknesses of everybody and how do we
get up to speed on that as fast as
possible and I met a manager there who
had said something really interesting he
said you know when when I buy a new car
it comes with an owner's manual so I
know how to operate it but when I work
with a new person who's way more complex
than a car I don't get anything and so
I'm kind of starting from square one
when in fact they have all these
experiences that could teach me
something from their past about how to
work with them better in the present in
the future and so what you did his name
is Aurora Skolnick he sat down and he
wrote up a one-pager on how to work with
him effectively what are his strengths
what are his weaknesses what are the
triggers that bring out the worst in him
what are the the moments that bring out
in the best in him and then he didn't
stop there he asked his team to write
their user manual for him so that he
could gauge his own self-awareness and
of course he found the team's house much
more insightful and accurate than his
own because of the blind spot factor in
part but now every new person who works
with him gets that one pager and gets to
immediately start as if they've known
him for a month or two and say okay you
know here are the things I might want to
adapt if if I want to be really
effective with this manager and so I've
gone I've gone and done that I asked a
bunch of people who work with me to
write my user manual and it's very
simple the questions are what are my
strengths what brings those out what am
i weaknesses what brings those out what
are my blind spots and what do you know
now about working with me that you wish
you had known when we first started
working together oh great invaluable
what what is what are some of the
answers to that last one
but the last one I've gotten a few funny
ones one one that really caught me off
guard was it really bothers you deeply
at your core when somebody pretends to
know something that they don't you you
just all of a sudden go from being a
pretty friendly affable person to to
just in intense prosecutor mode which
was a novel a novel observation for me I
got it I got another one that said that
I think the exact quote was that I am
unaware that sometimes when I say an
idea is not good I just crushed
somebody's three months they've invested
in that idea and Here I am thinking I'm
helping them move on you know more
efficiently yeah not not at all aware of
how much they've already invested in the
idea so maybe you're doing both I think
that probably do it better to better the
crush three months of effort and save
them the next three years but agree but
maybe maybe they don't have to be
crushed at all they can bring that down
a little more gently you're just very
strongly squeezed but then on the other
side of that I think mostly when we
timber we talk about blind spots we
think about our weaknesses right so
there are things we're not good at but
we don't realize it and we can't see
them because we're we're inside of our
own heads we also have blind spots about
our strengths hmm you might call them
great point great point
they're there things are good at that
you don't even know you're good at it
yeah and really good point I think that
you you need to see those through other
people's eyes too so I have some some
colleagues who develop this great tool
at the University of Michigan it's
called the reflected best self exercise
and I have all my students do it MBA is
undergrad senior executives everyone in
between and they often come back and say
it was eye-opening and occasionally even
life-changing what what you do is you
reach out to usually fifteen to twenty
people who know you well you get to
choose them often different walks of
life so some colleagues maybe a boss a
friend a family member and you ask them
to tell a story about a time when you
were at your
and you collect all these stories it is
the most delightful week of emails you
will ever get this is how amazing you
are again and again again but then you
have some work to do you have to analyze
the stories and find the common themes
and figure out okay what is the portrait
of me when I'm at my best and what is it
that activates those strengths and I
first did this my first year of grad
school and I I learned that that
apparently I didn't realize this but one
of my strengths was actually recognizing
other people's strengths
it showed up in almost every story was
you know I was at my best when I was
hoping someone else be at their best and
so I said I've got to make that part of
my job I have to figure out a way to do
that because I love it and people are
telling me that I'm good at it or at
least that they like it and I never
would have thought of that just did not
cross my mind and so it's it's an
exercise I'd like to see people do you
know I think every couple years because
sometimes you you have new people in
your life who see different strengths
your strengths evolve you find new ways
to activate them and I'm a big fan of
that exercise I love it any guidance I
have not no I've done the opposite which
is I supposed on brand for my pistol or
self or brand of self flagellation well
that it wasn't specifically my
reflective person self but I did a 360
interview process with a whole group of
people I've worked with and as as Joe
Gebbia one of the cofounders of Airbnb
yeah said to me when we were doing our
podcast for me when we were talking
either way he did it all so that was
like am I the only one who had like a
near nervous breakdown and just wanted
to cry in my car he's like he's like no
same thing happened to me and I was like
[ __ ] man that was rough
it's like because I big part of what
made it so rough for me is the way we
did it I think this is how it's
typically done but I've only done it
once you get all this feedback some of
which is very very can be very blunt and
very brutal which is all anonymized and
for me that is very hard not because I
want to
legend the people who gave me a hard
feedback but because I want to fix ya or
apology I want to fix things or
apologize for past transgressions or
mistakes or bad delivery or whatever
might be and I can't do that
when it's anonymized and the toner won't
give you the names of course yeah even
if you try to kind of trick them into it
by triangulating which which I'm not too
proud to say I tried and really tough so
I like the idea of this reflected best
self exercise though not to offset all
of the psychic damage done by the 360
but because I don't know if I don't know
if if you have observed this in yourself
I've certainly observed it in myself and
that is and in many of my friends who
are good problem solvers they are
rewarded for solving problems whether
it's in math class in primary school or
for solving thorny dissertation issues
or solving problems with a marketing
campaign or spaghetti code or whatever
it might be and as they're continually
positively reinforced for solving
problems they begin to look at the world
through the lens of finding problems and
yep I certainly have done that and as a
result I'm never looking for the rarely
have I looked for the strengths that are
going on see and I'm just looking for
all the things that are screwed up or
the weaknesses or the Achilles heels so
that I can fix them and I think um more
and more convinced I'm really glad you
brought this up that it is equally
important to look for those bright spots
as you put it not just the blind spots
really so really important I think so
and it's funny I don't meant for a Rick
Price who is trained as a clinical
psychologist before he moved into the
organizational world and he he used to
have a code with his wife that she would
just always remind him Rick sympathy not
solutions what would I tell you
something I do not necessarily want you
to fix it I just want you to know I just
want to know that you care right I want
to feel
and I think for those of us who like to
solve problems and probably especially
for those of us who are men that's it's
probably sage advice but the interesting
thing that that that I think that
surfaces for me is there's another
reason why you want to know what your
strengths are because we often miss
apply them or overuse them there's
there's research from from the center
for creative leadership which has shown
that one of the ways that you identify
career derailers is you look at
strengths that people overuse so you
know you've you've gotten reinforced all
your life for being assertive and then
you talk over people in meetings so much
that nobody else can get it worded you
you know you've been reinforced for a
lot of your career for having charisma
and that becomes a crutch and you know
prepared it for the talks that you give
and you end up you know kind of
underperforming or under-delivering and
you know that's of course I think when
you think about yourself as a problem
solver that's a case potentially if
strengths overused and so one of the
things that I've taken out of the
reflected best self is I don't just want
to be clear about what my strengths are
I want to know when is an appropriate
time to use them and when might be a
time to actually say you know I'm going
to turn off this strength so that
somebody else can use that strength yeah
yeah definitely or turn off that
strength so that you don't use it to
cover for weaknesses that perhaps you
should yes yes right that's certainly
something that I've experienced
personally as well it's easy to become a
hammer looking for nails what we only
have a few minutes left but I'm really
curious to know you mentioned some time
back the architecture of your week right
now you have some days that are working
on projects or talking to family but no
one else and I I have and this is fairly
common among a lot of the high producing
individuals I've come across
I know Jack Dorsey did this for quite a
while and maybe he still does but kind
of separating out days not just portions
of days but days for very specific
things
focus or higher in focus or fill in the
blank and for instance you know we're
recording this on a Friday when I do any
recording I try to do my recording on
Mondays and Fridays and I also try to
place the vast majority of my phone
calls or admin type tasks that I need to
be involved with in some sense on
Mondays right so I do have a weekly
structure I also have kind of certain
daily non-negotiables that give me a
structure around which to build
everything else provides me with a sense
of control that I find very helpful but
also a it puts a lot on autopilot so
that I'm not making a lot of extraneous
decisions so I'd love to hear if you
have any routines or activities whether
it's on a weekly or a daily basis that
you do very consistently and that could
be like the first two hours of your day
it could be the first what you do in the
first hour could be the last half-hour
it doesn't really matter but are there
any particular routines that you treat
is very important for yourself you know
I I did for a long time and there's so
some that I use but I have become little
less routine driven in the past few
years I think in part because I the the
the moment we talked about in the
classroom earlier of if kind of losing
track of the lesson plan and just
following the student questions that's
really unusual for me I tend to be so
laser focused in linear that I worry and
not being flexible and adaptable enough
and so one of the routines I've been
working on is just being comfortable
shifting my routine but I'm that way so
the things the things I'll tell you the
changes that I made to new routines that
I found most helpful one is I as a
morning person I used to try to do all
my creative work in the morning because
I knew that was when I was most alert
and then I read a bunch of research that
you actually do your most creative work
when you're a little fuzzier because
that's when your thinking is more
nonlinear it's when you make more
expected leaps and you know kind of free
associations and so now what I'll do is
at night before I go to bed when I know
I want to write the next morning I still
like to write when I'm fresh so that it
actually makes sense but the night
before I'll actually start jotting down
some ideas it might be a couple
sentences it might be an outline and
then I've got some hopefully some novel
material to run with in a more organized
way in the morning and so you can
obviously flip that if if you're a night
owl and say huh maybe I actually have
some creative ideas in the morning when
I feel like I can't think straight you
don't want to think straight if you're
trying to be creative so that's that's
one that I really like another one that
I've adopted recently which which has
been extremely productive for me is I
actually take phone calls right after
workouts because I've found that right
after workout I'm just not I'm not very
I'm not in work mode yet mm-hm and so I
feel like it needs some kind of
transition space to get back into focus
and and oftentimes like I just wasted
the half hour
you know after after I waste or cardio
and so I might as well have had a
conversation that time and so that's
become whitespace and then my my last
favorite routine which which is
definitely on the new side is I actually
go to sleep listening to podcasts I for
years I would read or watch TV going to
sleep but it's so much more relaxing to
not look at a screen yeah and I find
that I the information a little bit more
deeply than if I had read it and I also
fall asleep faster yeah sounds sounds
like win-win I haven't tried going to
sleep with podcast you have a favorite
bedtime podcast or types of podcasts I I
don't like I don't like our kinds of
podcasts bedtime because I didn't want
to be awake and learn from them I did I
just did against the shrink next door in
a few nights which was fascinating and I
ended up staying up way too late one
night because I just wanted to know
where the story went the other nights it
was great I did say I did cereal that
way and so I guess it's mostly more of
the either the
narrative or fiction style shows cool
what is your workout regimen look like
you mentioned exercise so I I do I lift
weights twice a week I do my target is
three days a week of cardio which is
usually a mix of an ultimate frisbee
game tennis match and elliptical and
then lately actually just a few weeks
ago I got back on a diving board for the
first time you know I retired half my
life ago and I had not been on a real
diving board in more than a dozen years
and got back on to try to relearn some
of the old the old tricks which hurt
very badly the next morning but has been
there's been a lot of fun and a good
workout too what prompted getting back
into the diving a couple things one I
was I happen to catch some I think the
senior national us finals and after
spending six years of my life almost
every waking hour either thinking about
it or doing it you know the moment I
watch it I want to get back into it
again and also I'd been teaching our
kids some techniques and so it seemed
like it was it was a good time to get my
skills back in order a lot of we could I
mean I've we're not even a tenth of the
way through my notes it sounds like
you're your early day lesson plans but I
know we we have to wrap up shortly let
me ask this and maybe one or two
questions after this but if you could
put a quote message symbol anything you
want on a billboard you've probably
heard this question before but
metaphorically speaking to get a message
out to billions of people let's say what
might you put on that billboard could be
honest that was easy
yeah I think the most meaningful way to
succeed is to help other people succeed
mmm take it that's kind of the way you
live your life so no see you guys there
yeah try a try
I and certainly the way that you have
lived your life it's I feel like you're
just getting started I'm very excited to
see what you do next and people can
certainly learn more at Adam grant not
net is that correct as far as I know as
far as you know as far as I know and
then on social on Twitter at Adam M
Grant Instagram Adam grant Facebook Adam
M grant is there anything you would like
to point people towards anything else
you would like to say recommend for
people encourage people to check out
anything at all that you'd like to say
before we wrap up maybe maybe just one
thought on productivity because it's we
talked a bunch about it and it's such a
core theme for you and your audience I
think one of the mistakes that people
make when they try to boost their
productivity is they're focusing on the
wrong goals I don't think being more
productive is actually that motivating
words today more words today whoo
I think that you know for me
productivity is a means to an end and
I've always been more productive when I
found a project that I care about or you
know a topic that I'm really intensely
curious about and I think that that
frequently when you feel like you're not
productive it's it's not necessarily
because you're lazy or because you have
bad habits it's because you're not
working on the right projects yeah and
you haven't found the ones that are
intrinsically motivating and meaningful
to you and so I think that you know I
guess I would just say you know I think
if productivity is your goal maybe
you've got the wrong goal that's a great
point that is a fantastic point and very
well said yeah maybe it's not how you
process email maybe it's impotent goals
[Laughter]
maybe it's the wrong project that's a
great great way to put it
well Adam thank you so much for taking
the time today this has been a lot of
fun thank you for having me Tim it's
been it's been a delight and a treat to
joint yeah definitely so I'm sure my
audience will have more questions for
you so maybe we do around to at some
point
but for now this is a great first
installment and I really appreciate you
making the space to do this and for
everybody listening I will have links to
everything we discussed
lots of details all the books everything
else at the page for show notes as per
usual Tim dot blog forward slash podcast
or you can find everything Adam thank
you again thank you let me close with
one question for you yes yes you can
decide what you want to run it or not
but if far away I would love to know
what big projects is on the horizon for
you next and what your your biggest
challenge is right now oh yes it's a big
big things on the horizon for me are
some very large scientific projects
involving researchers and studies
related to mostly classical psychedelics
is applied to what are considered widely
intractable psychological or psychiatric
disorders whether that is PTSD or
treatment resistant depression or I've
already helped to fund studies at places
like Johns Hopkins or eating disorders
there's a very long list and that that
would be very large project and more of
a series of projects coming up let's see
biggest challenge biggest challenge
would be perhaps wanting to disappear
for a while for an extended period of
time which I've been doing in increments
of weeks but feeling a very strong call
to sort of disappear off into the
wilderness for a while
and struggle is too strong a word but
feeling perhaps conflicted about the
best way to do that
and
if I feel confident that I and my
support structure will figure it out in
some way but yeah kind of reconciling
that it's a very difficult to explain
feeling it's really more of a like a
very core emotional or visceral drive
that I have without much left brain
analytical it's an Excel spreadsheet
data to support it
and I think coming from a life where I
have certainly over relied on that
analytical machinery III think it's
going to take me some very interesting
places so it's it's just really building
up the courage or dare I say faith oh my
god what a word that is to sort of
follow the feeling and believe that the
like the the understanding will come
later so that's maybe a very strange
answer but that's interesting what I
like about it is you get so much done
that you can disappear for a long time
and still be annoyingly productive one
other thing I was just tough mind
wandering about is you got LeBron and
his trainer who are your next dream
guests and not if you could have anybody
yeah you know who I'd love to have on
and the timing might actually be pretty
good is that they're there quite a few a
lot of the names no one would recognize
but many of my old mentors and
professors and I just recorded one that
should be coming out soon but I would
really enjoy to have a long conversation
with Oprah and also with Howard Stern
and they both they both recently had
books come out so I think the timing
could be decent it would only be worth
doing if they were willing to really
play ball and have a long-form
conversate
like this one but I find both of them
endlessly fascinating and I think that
their their abilities if you kind of
look between the the if you listen
between the notes of music so to speak
to really observe how they can craft
conversations navigate interviews and so
on
it's it's really remarkable and not to
mention the macro level perspective of
their careers but those would be two
that come to mind
that's very cool well you kind of want
them to interview you then experience
yeah well I mean certainly both of them
are pretty good at saying oh you're
gonna interview me
wait a second I have some questions for
you so who knows but I think that would
be I think that would be fun if they're
willing to play ball right I wouldn't
want to have someone drag them kicking
and screaming into doing it because I
don't think either side would enjoy that
but if they were if they were game I
think that a long-form conversation with
either both of them would be would be
quite fun and thanks for asking
no I look forward to hearing both of us
to be continued on that one and I will I
will let you get back to your day but
Adam speaking of to be continued as we
said before recording it is no small
miracle that we haven't actually he
bumped into each other at given the many
many concentric or I should say
overlapping circles that that we we live
and operate in so it's it's nice to to
spend this amount of time on the on the
phone having this conversation and
hopefully be able to share some share
some food break some bread raise a drink
at some point in the not-too-distant
future I will look forward to that in
the meantime thank you again for having
me of course and to everyone who is
tuning in thanks so much for listening
and until next time take a peek at
teamed up log forward slash podcast
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday event provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by zapier
z AP ie are you may in your own mind say
zapier but it's not safe here it's
zapier like happier they are a new
sponsor but not new to me as a service
at all I've been using them for many
years now if you run your own business
think about all the hours and hours
maybe
endless hours you spend moving
information from one software program to
another all because they don't easily
work together well now they can
automatically thanks to Sam pure my team
has been using zapier for years as I
mentioned which helps us with a ton of
tasks including let's just take one
example connecting Facebook Ads
campaigns to our email platform you can
also as I do automate the posting of
your Instagram photos to all social
platforms this is saved me and my team
hundreds of hours alone my team has also
raved about zapier support which is very
important if things go sideways you've
want to be able to reach someone and in
their words it is in a class of its own
class without notes
verbatim quote from one of my employees
as with all sponsors of this podcast we
try to test everything ourselves and we
have used
zapier as full paying retail customers
that is we paid for the service long
before we ever had contact with the
company as a sponsor they support more
than 1,500 business applications so the
possibilities for automating processes
are virtually endless you may know if
you've read the 4-hour workweek the
third step is automation not adding
headcount to a messy problem to try to
fix it but automating as much as
possible you want to eliminate automate
and only then delegate and zapier is one
of the best pieces of automation
software that have ever come across it
connects all of your business software
and handles work for you so you can
focus on the things that matter in those
things you're good at for instance
instead of trying to cobble stuff
together or code to learn more try it
out go to zapier dot-com slash to him
connect the apps use most and let zapier
take it from there you can do a million
things as one more examples after lets
you instantly engage with leads send
them to a crm or spreadsheet and then
notify your choice they can act the fast
and like I mentioned very briefly the
beautiful part is that you can build the
solution you need in minutes without
writing code or asking a developer for
help so join the 4.5 million people or
more at this point who are saving an
average of 40 hours per month by using
zapier now for a limited time try SAP
your free by going to our special link
zapier zap2it car.com slash Tim that's
zapier comm slash Tim for your free
14-day trial check it out zap e.com
slash tip this episode is brought to you
by peloton I love peloton peloton is a
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right to your
home you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into your schedule
making it to the studio or dealing with
some commute to the gym I have a pallet
on bike in my master bedroom at home and
it is one of the first things that I do
in the morning I wake up meditate for 20
minutes and then I knock out a short 20
minute drive usually high-intensity
interval
or hit then I take shower and I'm in
higher gear for the rest of the day it's
beautifully convenient and has become
something that I actually look forward
to and I was skeptical in the beginning
I didn't think I would dig it and I
really do
you have a lot of options for one if you
like you can ride it live with thousands
of other peloton riders from across the
country on the interactive leaderboard
keep you motivated I tend to use a lot
of the classes on demand and have four
to six of them that I've bookmarked and
use over and over again there are up to
14 new classes every day with thousands
of classes on demand and there are a
variety of workouts to choose from 45
minute classes 20 minute burns hip hop
rock and roll low-impact or high
intensity pick the class structure and
style their works for you peloton has an
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in your city they really do have great
instructors of every possible
personality and style and you can find
one that you love no matter what you're
in the mood for personally I use Matt
Wolfers a lot but I use a bunch of them
I'm promiscuous and enjoy classes
through a lot of their instructors with
real time metrics you can track your
performance over time and continue to
beat your personal bests I do not think
the gamification would work for me and
they really hit the nail on the head it
does work at least for me tremendously
well to keep me pushing consistently so
discover this cutting-edge indoor
cycling bike that brings us to do
experience to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go to one peloton
calm let's spelled o + e PE l OT o am
calm enter the code tim podcast all one
word a check out and get $100 off
accessories with your peloton bike
purchase get a great workout at home
anytime you want go to one peloton calm
and use the code tim podcast to get
started
you